I'd seen all these negative things
saying, Oh, if you're a Trump supporter,
you're a Nazi, you're this, you're
that. And I'm not those things.
I love my country.
I love my president.
Okay.
Probably
three,
two,
one.
I disagree because I have literally
gotten death threats for expressing my
public opinion on politics, on
supported the president. I mean,
I'm not going to stop
expressing my opinion,
but I still disagree that
I feel safe doing so.
I think most Americans don't at this time.
I do not believe that
suppressing my opinions from
people does anything good for
the, for the betterment of society, but
it's part member of the LGBT community.
It's pretty hard to hold those views.
Um,
and I just purposefully make a decision
that I'm going to be responsible for my
own safety and um, I don't let
anybody intimidate me that way.
Me,
I'm a skateboarder and an industry that
is pretty much dominantly liberal where
the graphics are of Trump shaking hands
with the KKK. I've been spit on before.
I've been cursed at.
I've had my board tried to be broken from
skateboarders even though I don't feel
safe at wearing it publicly,
I will continue to do so because
I will not have my voice silence
issues about
three two.
Why
I somewhat agree that they're
not important. Let me tell
you, let me explain why.
Because the same issues of the black
community affect all communities and if we
are Americans,
if we truly consider ourselves Americans,
my issues are no different from his
issued or hurry shoes or her issues or her
issues or his issues,
whether you're white or
black or brown or green.
I'm going to say I strongly
disagree and all due respect.
I disagree because there are different
issues in the black community then are in
other communities. There's higher crime
rates, there's higher abortion rates,
there's crime and violence
within this community.
There's a lot of hatred
within my community being
black against police officers
and those are specific
to the black community.
That is a very good point, but we
as Americans, whether you're black,
brown or white, you have a certain
obligation to the civil society.
So I have the obligation to stop
when the police officer says stop.
So I'm giving that as an example,
which is happened in many cases where
abuse has followed because the black runs
and he fights back.
I agree with that,
but
what you just said, you took 20 seconds
to explain a black issue, so he,
it is a problem, but of course everyone
is responsible for that problem,
but this community is hurting and they're
just as American as everybody else.
Oh, ball three two. What
I strongly agree that we need the wall.
It's not a matter of racial issues,
but national security, let
me say that first. First off,
every one out of every three
illegals comes with a federal crime,
whether it's murder or rape
or even drug cartel. Also,
we talked about black issues.
What about the illegal immigrants
that come that are dreamers,
but what about the American black
dream or his dream is to be a lawyer.
His dream to go to college and his dreams
to become something and get out the
hood. The Sally, we allow
these illegals to one pass.
Those who are waiting for a long time
to illegally come to the country because
there is a difference and it's
almost a slap in the face.
I do know at my school,
it's a public university.
They give out free college to
undocumented students. Yet here I am.
I come from a middle class family,
but I don't get any scholarships
like I get very little.
I can barely afford college at these
people who aren't even US citizens.
They get all these benefits that I myself
as an American citizen can't get. Yeah,
I somewhat agree to this. I think
the wall is, is useful and essential,
but the real issue is what can we do
to make our country have a much easier
system to,
for people to come in in a legal fashion.
It's the procedure that is too
difficult, too long, too cumbersome.
We'd love to have him come in. They
benefit us, they help us to grow.
They provide new ideas,
but let's be rational about this and to
keep it equal with the citizens of this
country who are already here.
Aye.
Three. Two. Why?
I guess the reason I somewhat agree,
it depends what you mean by a support.
If anyone Derris to mess with her,
I'm gonna kick their ass.
So like she's got my support 100% but
if you're asking me as a Christian,
I'm going to loves him and matter
what they are. We're all, like I said,
it's an American issue and we're
all supposed to give this together.
If it's contrary to natural law,
which it is in my view,
then I don't agree with
it. However, I can,
like you as a person with the LGBT
community that is in a pretty much has
morphed into a gay rights organization.
So they fight for rights that are
outside of the natural rights of the
declaration of
independence, life, liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness within
the boundaries of natural law.
So that's why I don't support the
LGBT community in bear activism,
but I do support them as human beings
with the same rights as I have no extra
rights, no extra right to
marry. Same Sex, but the same,
right as I have
put your, put your right, say you
can marry whoever you want. Oh,
very good. Okay. Good point.
There are a lot of features
in the LGBT community.
There are a little bit hard to deal with.
I don't identify with a lot of those
people identify as a transgender person,
not necessarily as a gay or lesbian
person. My wife on the other hand,
all of a sudden found herself
in a same sex marriage. Uh,
it was not something
that you signed up for.
Same sex marriage is a different thing,
but who cares who you love?
I'm very active in the Republican Party
and I'm trying to make a big inroads
with the religious freedom and the super
conservative religious people because
they need to learn to deal with me
because I'm going, I'm not going anywhere.
You know, you live your life,
you doesn't agree with my life.
I shouldn't feel compelled to affect
your life because I don't agree with it.
Is it good role model or are
three, two, one
hell yeah. Probably gonna
get a lot of flack for this.
I strongly agree. He's strong
and he is fighting for Americans.
He listens to what we want and yeah,
he doesn't always tweet the best stuff,
but I mean everybody's done that.
But the fact of the matter is that he
has principles and now he's standing for
what he believes in and he's taking
us to the future. A safer, better,
stronger America for all of us.
A reason why someone agrees because I
don't think any president should be a role
model for children. I think there
should be a role model for American,
like American men and grown adults.
So I don't think Trump should be a role
model for children because if so he had
to be PC all the damn time,
which does nothing but heard Americans.
He's the old school. Tell you
straight up, see your face.
The doctor that tells you the truth,
he tells you you got to lose a hundred
pounds and stop smoking and you'll die.
You get mad,
you might get assaulted,
but you find out he's only
one telling you the truth.
I somewhat agree as well because I think
that he's a good role model because he
sets out what he's going to do and then
he goes and does it and he's also a good
role model because of some
of the things he says,
which is not acceptable and
that is what real life is about.
It's not that somebody is perfect
and never make some mistake.
People make mistakes.
They repent from their mistakes and
they go out and do something positive.
Three, two, one. Ah,
that's such a hard one.
I did lose a couple of friends.
I went to school with a Trump shirt on
and I brought a Trump flag and waved it
around.
I had a couple teachers get really mad
at me and that may have affected my grade
at the end of the year,
even though I lost some relationships.
I've built really good friends and I
just really get along with who think
similar to me or accept what I think.
They don't have to agree with me.
But if you're in a community where
people can accept you for who you are,
those are the true people you need
to surround yourself in. I mean,
I lost friends, family
members, supporters,
business associates.
When I came out for Donald Trump
in 2017 February at the grammys,
I wore dresses. I said make America
great again. So I knew I would, you know,
create a stir but hitting number
one on iTunes, Amazon billboard,
my album rose to number one because of
Trump supporters. So I've lost things.
What I've also maintained this new
community based on who I truly am,
know any relationship that you lose as
a result of supporting Trump has no real
relationship anyway because he's
only there temporarily. I mean,
this is what everybody keeps forgetting.
I mean,
this guy is only going to be here
for what, another four or five years.
And so I want to remind everybody of that.
You know,
it's not the end of the world. Not
yet. It's getting there, but not yet.
Great again. Alright, three,
two,
one.
I mean it's Kinda easy.
Oh, come on. You can get over here.
I strongly agree. Um, there's some issues.
The man has got some idiosyncrasies
to drive us all a little bit nuts,
but overall, I mean, he's a businessman.
He knows how to make business happen.
I mean, we're, we're talking the
fact that we're even talking Sherpa.
Some people are grumpy and
don't like what he tweets,
but you're having conversations about it.
He's waking up.
So he is making America great again, is
making America, dare I say it woke again.
Trump is making America great again,
but the people around him are trying to
undermine him. And even in his own party,
he can only do so much.
He's not a dictator.
And this is where we
have to remember that.
Okay.
That's
right.